Speaker 1: Remember that The David Pakman
Show is made possible by members who sign
up at Join Pakman Dotcom.
Everyone is very, very special.
Let's go to the phone lines.
David Pakman dotcom slash discord, starting
with.
Oh, I don't know.
Let's start with let's start with D.J. from
Montana, D.J. from Montana.
You're on the air.
Speaker 4: Hi, David, how are you?
Can you hear me?
Yes, I can.
I'm doing great.
My name is David.
I am going to pay my subscription in two days,
and I couldn't be more proud.
And I just wondered if you could tell everyone
something that that drives you to do what
you do.
Maybe there's an event or a person in the
past.
That's all, thanks.
Speaker 1: No, there is no such event or person
I hate, I mean, it's you know, we I want to
inform the people.
I want people engaged.
I want people committing to things that are
important to them, to them.
It's not up to me to tell you what that should
be, but hopefully to let you know that there
are things happening in the world that you
should be paying attention to and that your
involvement is a good thing and that we should
all aspire to get involved.
But there are I sadly have no Black Swan event
I can point to, David.
Speaker 4: Well, that's OK.
Thanks for your time.
Speaker 1: All right, very good.
And we will welcome that membership payment
with wide open arms, as you can imagine.